كاس موسم الرياض تخطف الانظار ذيرنا يحذر
زميله من الانتقال الى تشيلسي واسكالوني
يفضل ميسي على مارادونا هذه الاخبار
وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
الى ستاد الملك فهد الدولي في العاصمه
الرياض والحدث هو كاس موسم الرياض بين
النجوم وفريق النصر والهلال وستشهد
المباراه وجد الجميع نجوم الفريق الفرنسيه
في مقدمتهم بطل العالم ليو ميسي
ونيمار
كما ستكون مواجهه الاولى بين رونالدو
وميسي خارج القاره الاوروبيه وقد تكون هي
الاخيره ايضا
بعد تجربه الفاشله مع نادي تشيلسي حذر
مهاجم المانيا يتم فينار زميله في فريق
لايف كريستوفرنجو من الانتقال الى النادي
اللندني و تشير التقارير الاعلاميه الى
قرب حسم صفقه انتقال اللاعب الفرنسي الى
انجلترا مقابله 55 مليون يورو وكان بيرن
قد مر باوقات صعبه بعد الانتقالي الى
البلوز قبل ان يعود مجددا الى فريقه
السابق
وبعد نحو شهر من تتويج الارجنتين بكاس
العالم خرج مدرب الفريق سكولوني يقول انه
يقدم ميسي في عالم مارادونا واضاف المدرب
بان مارادونا هو اسطوره لكن هناك شيء خاص
يجمعه مع ميسي بعد الفوز بالبطوله كما ان
العمل معه هو شيء سهل ولا يمكن تصحيحه ما
يفعله في التدريبات مثلا
واحدا من بين الكثيرين الذين يرون الان
بان ميسي يتجاوز مارادونا بعد فوزه
بالمونديال
كشف نجم مانشستر يونايتد السابق جي سي
نينجارد عن معاناته من اساءات مشجعي
الشيطا والحمر وقال النيجر في مقابله
بودكاست بانه كان يشرب الكحوليات كل ليله
للعرب من الواقع الذي كان يعيشون كما دخلت
والدته الى المستشفى بعد اصابته بالاكتئاب
جراء ما كان يحدث مع ابنها كما كشف الاندر
ايضا عن العديد من الامور الصادمه التي مر
بها في تلك الفتره